after threatening to veto it after
slamming Democrats after saying that we
must have full funding for that wall
with Mexico that I thought Mexico was
going to pay for anyway but I guess
we're forgetting about that after saying
that it must contain a deal to deal with
daca
Donald Trump has signed this just
massive 1.3 trillion dollar spending
bill that has a huge number of
conservatives furious with him but
weirdly he also vowed never to sign a
similar bill again very hard to figure
out what happened let's take a look at
what Donald Trump had to say at this
signing ceremony for the 1.3 trillion
dollar omnibus spending package Trump
said quote there are a lot of things
that I'm unhappy about in this bill
there are a lot of things that we
shouldn't have had in this bill but we
were in a sense forced if we want to
build our military we were forced to
have there are some things that we
should have in the bill but I say to a
Congress that I will never sign another
bill like this again I'm not going to do
it again nobody read it it's only hours
old now the only hours old and nobody
read it thing only seems to be a problem
I guess when Republicans don't like the
bill or some aspects of it and Trump
wants to I guess criticize something
also the idea here of I did it this time
but this is definitely the last time
it's sort of like the way a parent would
try to scold their kid that just took a
cookie again and this is the last time
that the parent is going to go along
with that type of thing it's it's just
this completely black and white sort of
framing that Donald Trump loves to put
out there while at the same time trying
to maintain sort of some connection to
everybody on the political spectrum it's
terrible Democrats are terrible I almost
vetoed it I thought about vetoing it
Republicans so you should like me for
that but I'm gonna sign it but this is
the last time so you don't have to be
too mad with me about the fact that I
did sign it doesn't really project
strength doesn't really project
consistency in any way and no too
conservatives spanning the gamut right
from conspiracy theorists on the right
to alt rightists to more traditional
ideological conservatives just furious
with donald trump over this the base
arguably in a sort of pseudo revolt
we'll start with Laura Ingraham a Fox
News host
long-term conservative radio host she
tweeted when Donald Trump signed this
bill missed opportunity by Donald Trump
by signing the spending bill
if he loses the House Dems will go
straight to impeachment then we have all
trite extremists and occasional attacker
of this program Mike Serna vich who
tweeted congratulations to my liberal
friends you're getting Congress back I
hope your party does more for you then
Donald Trump has done for his supporters
conspiracy theorist Paul Joseph Watson
of Alex Jones Infowars Fame getting in
on the action quoting an article from
Infowars
this is the day that the swamp one trunk
base revolts over signing a budget bill
and then we have uber conservative Ann
Coulter who was on a tirade last week I
will never sign another bill like this
again quoting Donald Trump yeah because
you'll be impeached and another one from
Ann Coulter as this was going on it's 3d
chess in parentheses there's never going
to be a wall and to add to the anger
over Trump signing this just massive
spending bill he has also angered the
pro-gun right within hours of signing
this bill which a lot of right-wingers
were furious with him for doing Donald
Trump put out a tweet about bump bump
stocks and firearms which has also made
a lot of his supporters furious saying
quote Obama administration legalized
bumped stocks bad idea as I promised
today the Department of Justice will
issue the rule banning bumped stocks
with a mandated comment period we will
ban all devices that turn legal weapons
into illegal machine guns I hate to it
MIT this but there's this totally toxic
subreddit on reddit called the V
underscore Donald and it's become kind
of a de facto epicenter for the
committed Trumpets and you should have
seen what was going on over there as
Donald Trump was saying we're banning
bumped stocks and I'm signing this
massive bill which by the way has very
little funding for that wall just
immediately when Trump signed the bill
and tweeted about the bump stock thing
people on the Donald which is considered
like the most committed community of
Trumpets in the United States tweeting
uh posting messages rather that they're
furious with Trump that this is just a
disaster Trump has betrayed them it's
all terrible and that type of dissent is
just not allowed on the Donald that that
is not looked kindly upon and moderators
starting to ban users by the dozens on
the Donald subreddit and they even had a
sticky message at the top of the
subreddit same something along the lines
of I'm paraphrasing here but instead of
being mad at Trump be mad at the
Senators and the members of Congress who
created the bill rather than just being
mad at Trump for signing it because
ultimately that's the bill he was
presented with and it's not really his
fault which is just a classic type of
response when you have someone who runs
on populist rhetoric but they're
actually an authoritarian right the
authoritarian populist populist rhetoric
but they are actually authoritarian in
office they do whatever the hell they
want in office people start blaming
others because of the cognitive
dissonance in this case they said hey
don't blame Trump blame the House and
Senate who put together this bill so the
the part I want to sort of dig into here
is there are people who will hear me
talking about what Trump did and how the
right is angry and they'll say well
David it sounds like Trump did things
you like he signed this spending bill
and he said he's banning bump stocks so
why don't you like Trump why don't you
defend Trump this isn't as simple as
it's the right analogy the enemy of my
enemy is my friend right it's not that
type of thing we're talking about a
belligerent and incompetent danger like
a systemic fundamental danger to the
country in the world the left isn't just
going to come to the guy
side because he manages every once in a
while not to do the worst possible thing
or said something just minutely sensible
right this is someone with no actual
underlying political philosophy who is
going to legislate in a way that is
completely haphazard and unpredictable
when you combine the total lack of
knowledge about politics with what's
really his primary desire which is he
wants to be liked and he wants to be
able to check off boxes that can at
least be touted as accomplishments this
is the kind of garbage you get right the
left is known it for a long time maybe
the right now kind of starting to
realize that when you see the outsider
as a positive thing there's ways in
which the outsider idea can completely
backfire on you as well which is he ends
up signing a 1.3 trillion dollar sorry
trillion dollar spending bill that you
don't really like and says hey I think
we're gonna ban bump stocks and it is
not surprising in the least and the only
question now is whether the Trump is say
hey you know what he has abandoned us
and by the way I've been saying for more
than a year that they've been completely
bamboozled by Trump they say he's
abandoned us so we're going to abandon
him that's one possibility I actually
don't see that as the most likely
possibility I think the more likely
possibility is they sort of reinvigorate
themselves with the idea that hey
Hillary could have been president right
we don't have Killary we've got Trump
he's an outsider he's a political novice
he's going to do some things that we
don't like but let's stick with them for
the long-term here let's keep this going
to the extent that we can and prevent
Democrats from taking over in 2018 and I
think ultimately once they are presented
with the option Democrats maybe winning
anything in the midterms in 2020
whatever and just continuing to support
Trump they're going to go with Trump and
part of the evidence for that are those
results that I told you about from
illinois's third congressional district
the last last week where 20,000
Republicans voted for the unopposed Nazi
Holocaust denier we'll see ultimately
how
many Republicans in that district will
choose in November the Republican Nazi
Holocaust denier over voting for a
Democrat but I think in the long term
what you're going to see is that the
truly committed trumpet is going to
stick with Trump because Democrats are
just worse on every level send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show we'll be right back the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership